so now with that in our heads now we're
ready to differentiate this guy now
consider us so we can write this
underneath you in real life if you like
[Music]
that's right yeah yeah it's sort of like
yeah like babushka dolls sort of that's
exactly what is right okay all right now
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
try and work out how to differentiate
this thing okay but I need to change its
form into something that can talk in
ease if that makes sense because I know
how to deal with ease I don't know how
to deal with these other numbers okay so
here's how I'm gonna do it I'm gonna say
if y equals a to the X y equals e DX
right what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
replace that a with this okay I'm going
to use this result we just proved okay
so instead of writing a I'll write it as
e to the power of log a is that alright
let me write that e to the power of log
a there it is right there
you just told me those things were equal
right and you just try it on your
calculator and then that's to the power
of X because that's that's what I have
in the first night Sophia
you're talking about like how I do you
mean just this sure so the short answer
is this is actually a result which is
kind of it's a bit like Pythagoras just
there you've proved it once and then you
can just kind of use it right however we
like if I showed you guys this I
wouldn't expect you like just know it
off the top your head because we have
been doing explanations of logs all that
much we haven't been doing it as long as
we're doing Pythagoras so that's why I
went and did all that working to show it
if that's okay but you don't need to
redo it every single time just like you
don't need to redo Pythagoras every time
okay now why is this better because it
is better okay what's this if I just
don't take these two powers right
something power to a power I can write
this as e to the power of X log a is
that okay those powers just multiplied
by each other now what's great about
this is I know how to differentiate this
we know how to differentiate this we've
been doing ones like this for ages right
this like yeah this is this is just a
chain rule situation isn't it it's a to
the power of some other function okay so
I need to do the inside and then I need
to do the outside that's all I need to
worry about okay so let's let's have a
go let's see if we can do this okay the
inside function is that thing in the
power it's x times log a now a is just a
number so log a is also just some other
number can someone therefore tell me
what's the derivative of this like if I
gave you either the power of 5x the
number at the front is 5 so the
derivative of 5x is just 5 if I gave you
a weird one like it depend of PI X and
it pies a weird-looking number but it's
still just a number right so the
derivative of that guy would just be PI
ok now look carefully I know that looks
weird but log a like put in log 2 or log
5 or whatever it's just another number
do you agree it's just a weird dressed
up number so what would the derivative
of this big log a
there is the derivative of the inside
function
okay what's the other part of trailer
it's the derivative of the outside
function right the outside function you
dealt with the inside now we do the
outside and the outside is e to the
power of a thing what happens when you
differentiate e to the power of a thing
you just get back that same thing right
which in this case is e to the power of
X log a like so okay now we're pretty
much there like we've actually done
we've actually done the differentiation
I was a bit cheeky and I didn't write
the left hand side this is not Y anymore
this is the derivative of Y I do you
want e^x well I need to do here just to
tell you a teeny bit is to remember
whoops where's my red going see this guy
here that's what I started with see that
that's how I just rewrote this guy so
I'm just going to put it back to where
it was before I turned it into an e base
because I knew how to deal with those
bases but now I don't need to I can
write it in a simpler way this is just
I'll write it in the same color so you
can see this derivative equals that's a
to the X once you started with okay I
just rewrote it in a so I could deal
with it and then I multiplied it by log
a which is just a number that's it
that's the derivative now one of the
lovely things about this is you can
confirm it by looking at a result you
already know think back to the
derivative of e to the X that's the
common one that you know right does it
fit into this does the derivative EDX
fit this pattern because e to the X is
just a special version of this right the
one where we were moving the grass
around it's like we they locked up right
so let's just quickly figure out this if
I put in YZ everywhere you see A's what
would happen this guy at the front I'm
gonna write it as e to the X where Y
right here
I'm gonna replace every a with an e
which looks like this right what is that
Ln a that's log base a of a that's just
that's just one isn't it it's convenient
that my elves look so much like ones
okay and that's the a e to the X that we
already know was the derivative okay so
this is just the special version where
everything kind of cancels out neatly
okay so if you want you can put a big
box around that the derivative of any
exponential is going to be this yes
you're talking about this X power yeah
we were that the whole thing has been
switched around if you want to think
about it this way have a look at my
first line and then my third line do you
see they're all equal to Y wife was this
y equals that so I've just said oh that
e to the X log a let's just go back that
was nicer actually that was Nita it was
less writing John the derivative of any
exponential will be this if your
particular exponential is a then you get
e to the X log a which is e to the X
okay and if you want just go back to des
what you're still got there hopefully
and you can actually put in this as your
derivative curve and you'll get the same
result okay yes yeah that's exactly
right so this is why e to the X is
special because if you put in E in here
it sort of just disappears if that makes
sense okay except we just looked at the
picture of it